hey everyone this is lucy i'm a social
solutions architect working at amazon
web services and today i'll be sharing
with you how you can get started with
learning aws for free so i know on this
channel i've mainly been recommending
paid resources but many of you have been
reaching out asking if there's ways to
learn aws without having to buy video
courses or ebooks the good news is yes
there are tons of resources out there to
help you study for 80 certifications and
build your skills in aws it's not really
something you need to be spending a lot
of money on especially if you're a
full-time student or if you don't have a
steady source of income but the bad news
is because there's so many resources out
there it can be quite hard to filter
through all of them and figure out which
one you should be using and so in this
video i'll be sharing the top strategies
and resources that you can use to learn
aws without having to pay a single
dollar before we get started please make
sure you give this video a like and
subscribe to this channel if you'd like
to see more videos like this
alright so many of you might not know
this but aws is actually on a mission to
provide free cloud computing skills
training to over 29 million people by
2025. according to this press release
amazon has committed to investing
hundreds of millions of dollars towards
this mission and to help with this they
launched a platform called the aws
skills builder which aims to provide
high quality training to people all
across the world i've been using edible
skills builder a lot recently and it's
been really helpful for building my
skills in certain services in aws and in
my honest opinion it's the best platform
and resource to learn aws for free it's
basically a learning portal where you
can access everything from video courses
to lab exercises and practice questions
you can explore different learning plans
and there are over 500 courses available
to help you own your career and achieve
your goals all you have to do is to sign
up for a free account and you can get
started with your learning
now the next resource i'd like to
recommend is workshops.edu
this is something i recommended in my
previous video and a lot of you were
really surprised that there's a website
out there where you can find free
self-paced labs created by different
teams internally at aws this is an aws
site where you can find self-paced
workshops ranging from all levels of
difficulty so you can see there's level
300 level 200 level 100 as well and
there's a lot of workshops you can
choose from so for example this aws
networking workshop you can see that it
covers the full spectrum of aws
networking all the way from the basics
of a vpc and subnets to the more
advanced configurations now aws
workshops are a really great resource to
sort of learn by doing so by following
along those workshops you'll be able to
improve your skills in aws and really
learn about how those services work deep
down
okay so the next resource is a video
series called back to basics it's an
ongoing series of videos that explains
examines and decomposes basic cloud
architecture best practices and each
episode is actually hosted by an aws
solutions architect i would recommend
back to basics for anyone looking to
familiarize themselves with
architectural patterns and get an idea
of how adipose services work together to
address common technical problems
the next resource is the aws free tier
and if you don't know already aws once
you sign up for an account gives you 12
months of access to many of our services
for free and these services you can use
them to a limited capacity without
having to pay a single dollar and this
comes in really handy because as you
probably heard me say over and over
again on this channel the best way to
learn aws is by understanding the
theoretical knowledge but more
importantly building and experimenting
and seeing how these services actually
work in the aws console and how all of
these services fit in together so to
make use of the free tier what you can
do is you can create your own aws
account set up a billing alarm to avoid
unnecessary charges and then you can
start to provision resources and
interact with these resources for
example you can see here that amazon ec2
has a free tier that provides 750 hours
per month for certain t2 micro and t3
micro instances i'll put a link in the
description box below that gives you an
overview of the services covered by the
aws free tier okay so by this point of
the video what i've mentioned is
resources that can help you with aws
certifications it can help you build
your skills in aws and it can also help
you understand some of the comment
architectures but i thought i'd mention
some other resources that can help you
understand the cloud computing industry
better and help you go deeper into your
learning once you have developed a basic
understanding of aws services the first
one is aws re invent videos reinvent is
an annual learning conference hosted by
aws for the global cloud computing
community you can watch as many of these
videos as you'd like for free on youtube
and there are some really cool keynote
speeches product announcements and
customer stories aside from re invent
aws has a bunch of other events and
webinars throughout the year for example
aws summit and aws innovate on youtube
you'll be able to find recordings for
some of those sessions too the second
one is abyss white papers there are
hundreds of free technical white papers
technical guides and reference diagrams
available on this website and reading
through them will help you expand your
knowledge of different aws use cases the
next resource is aws ramp up guides i've
recommended this in a previous video and
it's a really good way to find useful
resources grouped by different
categories so you can see by role by
solution or by industry and for example
if i click on one of the guides you can
see that the resources are centralized
and listed out in the document and the
final resource that i wanted to mention
is the aws twitch channel more
specifically a show called the aws power
hour you can watch the recorded episodes
on demand and it's a pretty fun and
engaging way to learn how to build on
aws alright so this brings us to the
very end of this video please give it a
like if you haven't already and
hopefully you found this video helpful
if you have any video suggestions please
leave it down in the comments below and
subscribe to the channel to stay updated
with future videos